he's gonna write a book and it's gonna
be like a self-help book called totally
honest yeah how honesty you know helped
me get in and out of crime and he's
going to be a bestseller it's going to
call on your podcast it's going to be
called meth cooked stick around
thank you to our sponsor Babel maybe you
have some travel plans this summer where
you can learn to speak like a local with
Babel because with Babel you can start
speaking a new language in just three
weeks get started right now with 55 off
your Babel subscription for our
listeners go to babel.com DPT that's 55
off at babel.com DPT spelled
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash DPT rules and
restrictions May apply they may hey
townies welcome to another episode of
dumb people town
it did happen on the same exact mountain
and I had the same ski patrol person uh
wheel me off the mountain oh my god
really are real joking is it the same
yeah it was in uh at Deer Valley Utah
that mountain done got us good broke
ankle was it a tree or a just a fall
that was actually really funny we can't
gloss over I don't want to what's up
that mountain done got us good broke
ankle Mountain broken mountain it done
God is good broke ankle mountain is just
hand stuffed
Dan Dana dude has like uh has like a
Gwyneth Paltrow flannel just hanging and
we already talked about this for a
listener I'll be Daniel as I usually in
some contexts always
wait did you hit a tree you just fell
weird no I didn't hit a tree actually
what I did hit I skied over uh you know
those little water bottles that you get
in an Uber the tiny ones yeah yeah there
was one of those litter without the
label on it so you couldn't see it worse
and I was skiing with my brother and I
was trying to show him you can be
control because he ski is very wild and
I was like you can be controlled while
on something Steep and I hit the stupid
thing and I broke my ankle oh my God
last question and then we got dump
stories
beginning or end of the trip or day
three day trip
90 minutes in oh no no I'm sorry buddy
and your brother's like no I'm gonna be
Reckless and you didn't teach me
anything damn yeah it's like Dan you you
and you're like I got a book how many
books do you have yeah we'll get into
that book it's sitting over again
shoulder Dan why don't we go here I have
a dumb story ready let's do it send it
by Ace of Finance at Dragon ilm let's do
it here's the headline Red Bull Bandit
who the Red Bull Bandit gives you wings
leads Vegas Police on Chase
there's so much of that are there
bullets in Vegas to me the most
surprising thing is that there are
police in Vegas it never ends for them I
mean they look they solved the uh Tupac
shooting in a second Dave that's a
different deal I imagine this is just
like I'm not commenting on that I
actually feel like the ice the Vegas
Police were very much uh highlighted in
the show Cops yeah like babies were
always there because there's fun things
happening in Vegas sure sure
um and then they canceled the show and
now what are the Vegas Police doing
their police work they are I don't know
they're on strike with the wga
no solidarity here we go Las Vegas okay
Las a self-described Red Bull addict
what's the first thing you when you
introduce yourself to someone Dan and a
dude what do you say about yourself Dana
dude espresso addict thank you that's
what you say Dan Daniel Van Kirk what do
you say Rochelle Illinois addict right
that's what you say I say Randy scar
Monster Energy Drink addict is what I
say is right I mean what's I don't know
why what do you say James I say Jason
scar I have a twin brother we do comedy
and I also have a parent I don't know
why anyone would start by saying they're
a red self-described five-hour energy
who are you too much information you're
leading with too much information let
police on a trace which reached speeds
of exactly what you would say if you
were writing this out how many miles per
hour this isn't even a guess you're just
a hundred and thirty a hundred wow after
officer said
pepper sprayed an employee during a
robbery police arrested good for her
Eugene Davis White Guy probably deserved
it police arrested Eugene Davis and
Angela sharp on Thursday July 21st
record showed in July 20th Angie sharp
two employees at the Costco on Martin
Luther King Boulevard near Alta Drive
yeah just put on the on the walking tour
put it on witnessed a woman later
identified as sharp stealing a shopping
cart full of Red Bull cases she needs
everything she's an addict guys
estimated to be worth how much money oh
my shopping cart
also you're at Costco I'm gonna say a
hundred bucks okay
I'm gonna say like 48 bucks okay a
shopping cart full of Red Bull that's
like several cases of Red Bull yes uh
200 okay one of you is exactly right oh
snap now we get to play who do you think
is right you're gonna stick it inside
with yourself or take one of their
guests you have confidence Dan this is
like the Price Is Right Where I get
double the money double the money if you
get and you get the other person's
showcase here's the thing I'm a
celebrity and I get everything for free
it could be ten thousand dollars
one of our answers is Right would you
say 49 48 48 I'm sticking to 100. okay
I'm sticking in 200. I'll stick it 48. I
did a couple drops for Red Bull and now
I'm on there like you're one of our
people lists this happens
I get Red Bull sent to me all the time
more than you could have Philly drinks
and she's sharp remember I hosted those
Red Bull uh rapid races and all that
other stuff oh yeah
bring me back I loved it oh my God I got
to do the rafting races and I got to do
the box if you called those races uh
soapbox races all right ready yep
estimated to be worth
a hundred dollars oh there he is right
on the money OMG attempted to intervene
when sharp threatened to pepper spray
her that's right now remember sharp does
pepper sprayer Guys somebody goes on my
peppers for you stop just walk away walk
away I'm gonna pepper spray you is
usually you're cute you're cute to be
like okay yeah just follow you to your
car and get your license plate and then
you cause you got peppers and you know
Costco is gonna go
um we we're glad that you love working
here but do not follow people into the
parking lot we don't care you got
peppers from yeah has anyone here ever
been pepper sprayed uh no no have you
but no speaking of a segment now let's
do it how does it feel to get Peppers
yeah I don't want to go Rose speaking of
Vegas I'm sitting at the blackjack table
nearest to the exit at the Harrah's
Casino which you could it's just big
open area walk in and out Dan always
knows where the eggs Aaron molaring and
I sitting there one of my oldest friends
we're playing Blackjack and the dealer
like stops dealing and like looks to our
left and we look over and this guy sits
down or has sat down we didn't see him
and his every part of his face looks
like it's dripping My Eyes Nose sweat
mouth no he had just gotten pepper
sprayed oh my God and he's just like
like just disoriented and and uh they
had to come in and be like hey man you
okay and of course he didn't respond no
they give either and I don't know if
that happens to everybody who gets
perpetrate or how much of the can he got
he got a lot that's enough for me it's
like a bear spread yeah maybe he was a
self-described pepper spray E Yeah
an attic or he just Vaped guys and
that's why you don't Vape take that
cherry sweet cherry wood a man later
identified as Davis that'd be Eugene
then got out of the car and dragged the
full cart of Red Bull closer to the
vehicle the woman then pepper sprayed
the employee of the two suspects drove
off this is how you get Bandit you got
to be I mean you got it spray load it up
and go police obtain surveillance video
of the incident which showed the man was
wearing a Pittsburgh Steelers jersey on
Brandt very very still green yep an
employee then told police the same
suspects had stolen Red Bull from the
store the week before okay the second
time now we know steal Red Bull from the
store one shame on me shame on you
in that case
even more Red Bull had been stolen on
their first attempt estimated to be
worth now how much more
in dollars you know the first one they
had one car for 100 100 bucks give me
the money in the value of Red Bull you
think they got first first time they hit
this Costco up 140 140 180 okay 200. oh
my God boys
estimated to be worth 350. estimated to
be worth two thousand five hundred
dollars that is that is so much money
five shopping carts worth of Red Bull
come on listen this person is an addict
they own a stake in the company at this
point you're reselling you're right
you're a board member you're black
market in your Red Bull if you're
stealing twenty five hundred dollars
worth of Red Bull you better have gotten
the Mini Cooper you're outside of of
Stadium like you know you're outside of
whatever where the UNLV player you're
jumping in one of those flying squirrel
suits for red yes yeah
Wow Car appeared to be the same in both
instances this is where I'm kind of like
guys try harder a little bit appeared to
be they saw you coming you were there a
week before you sold 2 500 Where The Red
Bull but they remember you and got away
with it yes you go to a different
costume who has the balls to go back who
needs more did you go through all of it
in a week yeah that's great were they
already out they got to be selling it to
like bars who don't care right and then
why did they just take one I don't
understand why get ready for this by the
way boom boom how do you approach like
pull up to the back of a bar during the
day when someone's answering something
hey man uh you guys want some Red Bull
yes you guys haven't been uh white van
speaker stereo system offered I've been
recently I was
hey man I noticed you got a little uh
bump on the side of your car you know I
do uh Body Works I've seen that guy too
I'm like get out of here I had the guys
try to sell me stereotypes he's trying
to have it all right thank you so much I
really hope you drive right into a tree
out of my face
yeah okay get out of myself I hope you
drive into a tree so that you can then
put then you know because you know how
to fix your cars okay okay put your
skills to use police later learned about
a third case no that report happened Red
Bull that got stolen on July 14th at
another Costco yeah in that case a man
matching the same description as the
other two incidents Steelers Steelers
jersey yep was acting suspiciously with
a cart full of Red Bull cases a Dell
laptop computer if you're gonna steal a
Dell dude you stole a Dell yeah dude you
said is it the Pittsburgh
s-t-e-a-l-e-r dealers literally
a Dell laptop computer and a security
camera I love that he's stealing one of
the things that's probably also used to
convince catch him for stealing that's
so poetic yeah the man attempted to
leave that Costco with the merchandise
through a side door come on I mean you
know how everyone's like hey where
there's one way to get in and one way to
get out of Costco if you see anyone
taking a car to a side door and they are
hardcore about the ins and outs of
Costco I feel like at Costco they'll
like they'll run you down and shoot you
well we found out they'll get pepper
sprayed for Red Bull that's right the
man attempted to leave the Costco with
the merchandise to the side door when an
employee approached him the man said
quote you want some of this and then hit
the employee's face with his elbow what
okay no one should get hit but the
employee is way too close if you're
taking an elbow come on guys you've
watched them so much UFC in the last
year the elbow is very you're too close
yeah I mean what are you in the post I
also what did he think he was gonna get
do you want some of this do you want
some of this Red Bull yeah
I don't know why he keeps going to
Costco as well I don't know why he
doesn't diversify their other stores
is fantastic probably a bigger kids
they're everywhere
smart and fun you had to be powerful and
final smart and final if I were gonna
steal they'd let you go our friend Eric
Friedman when he was dating a very funny
writer when he was dating women they're
like you put the name like a little
descriptive thing about you in the
profile thing and it said cute and smart
to which he referred to her as uh when
he went out with her once and then ended
at cute and smart and final
at one point during the altercation the
suspect reportedly flashed a bit of
something black saying I will blast you
guys the suspect ran away without
stealing anything in that incident I
will blast you guys and then I'm gonna
leave everything here that I was going
for in a fourth incident what God police
learned that on July 13th this is the
day before the one I just talked about a
man with the same description same
Jersey entered a New Jersey business on
Charleston and Valley View Boulevard so
they said business at least we're not at
Costco right okay good good they're
learning
stole how many cases of Red Bull in that
one oh this isn't money just now we're
back there just kidding now we're a case
no compulsion this is not even would you
say an addiction yes it's not about the
Red Bull anymore
it gives you a rush Red Bull gives you
priors friends you make along the way it
really is that's what it's about it's
the process 20 cases it's a processing
uh I'm gonna go I mean how big is the
case how many things we're gonna get I'm
gonna go for three through
made 15 cases okay 10 cases all right he
stole 20 cases
Red Bull is the case that they gave me
if we added this up
so far we one time he didn't get away we
tried to also get Adele but the other
time he's we know he stole 20 cases
stole 2 500 worth of cases and then
stole a hundred dollars worth of cases
he's this is like in the matter of days
he's got that security camera though now
so he goes in I think he's still in
order no he didn't get away with that
one oh he didn't get away Dan I think
he's filling orders
uh when an employee confronted the
suspect He restored to said don't
approach me I have a weapon and I'll use
it if you approach me yeah it's a good
line that'll that'll work last Thursday
that's from die hard right you know what
I would say I'd be like you said me too
many times like don't approach me yeah
yeah I have a weapon and I'll use it if
you approach me yeah me redundant at one
point oh in a fourth incident we're
already there last Thursday an officer
noted that a car matched the description
of the one used in the robberies near
Arville and Blue Diamond Road I know
where that is that's right when you come
into town the driver failed to stop for
police and a chasing suit the driver
later identified as sharp that would be
Angela reach speeds of around 100 miles
per hour on the highway she later
stopped the car for about 15 minutes and
parked it and both she and Davis got out
so they were in the car together she was
the one driving yeah she's also the one
who pepper sprayed the employee is she
wearing the Steelers jersey no I think
he is no he is he's wearing students
while in custody Angela sharp told
police that she was the suspect in one
of the robberies she said quote I did it
because I'm addicted to Red Bull all
right so blame Red Bull well she doesn't
want them to find out who she's selling
to because they're going to go down
they'll run down that too yeah yeah
Davis faces charges of attempted robbery
burglary and robbery put those two
together he was being he's being held
Tuesday without bail due to a prior
believer attempted robbery burglary and
robbery aren't those all the same thing
I think once you do attempted robbery oh
that's because he didn't take he failed
he failed they ran out before the thing
sharp faces a charge of a driver
disobeying a police officer and robbery
so she always got away with it she's
being held Tuesday on a 25 000 bail wow
that's a lot of Red Bull oh yeah how old
48 cases is Angela sharp the Red Bull
addict who pepper sprayed an employee
I'm gonna say she's been around the
block
good things bad things have happened to
her sure where she's come to this point
sure yeah you're talking about the Red
Bull addiction or the crime
um all of it together okay all of it
together she's not a teenager no she is
she's 43. 43 47 47 39 39.
Angela Sharp
is 27 years wow do you want to guess how
old Eugene Davis is sure are Steelers
wearing I need a Dell computer and a
security camera yeah you want to go last
uh I'll go last okay 40 41 41. oh you
think it's a 27 and a 41 year old I do
32. he's your Mentor I think he's 41 and
32 so far I think maybe he's 18 and he's
trying to impress me wow wow yeah
here's to you Mrs Red Bull Robin she's
27 and Eugene Davis is
35.
that's not a bad age range
to 30 years I said 30 years there you go
uh Jay's got story two and when we come
back from the break book under cooked
Dana dude's new book we're going to talk
all about it uh we did his wonderful
podcast we talked about what was in our
fridge I'm assuming this is somewhat
building on that we'll get to that after
the break it's Dana dude in a boot on
dumb people toot we'll be right back I
like that hey now
[Applause]
let's overcook some of our dates and let
people know we have coming up I don't
know overcooked also a game that will
make you realize you and your family
have communication right have any of you
guys played over should meet be gray no
what is overcooked oh [__] have you
cleaned it no I have not it's just a
very simple kitchen game you're in a
restaurant everybody has their own
little character okay and you constantly
have to like
vegetables need to be chopped need to be
put in dishes need to be done things
need to get outside no it's a video game
it's very simple it's very fun your kids
would love it you would love playing it
with it but also understand going into
it overcooked you are going to realize
where your communication issues are in
your family it's so much fun already
stressing me out Dan it is stressful but
it's buried me out very it's overcooked
all right so hey we've got uh comedy
dates coming up yes we're doing I don't
know when this episode is dropping we
never know that because we're very far
out ahead but I'll say this if this
drops before May 18th 19th 20th we're
going to be at the Acme Comedy Company
in Minneapolis first time I've been
there in like maybe four years five
years great Club one of the best comedy
cities in in the world so I'm super
excited to go there hopefully we can
sell out those shows uh and then we're
going to be in San Francisco just
announced at the end of uh July July
21st 22nd June 14th we're going to be at
uh June 14th at The Comedy Store doing
tag it which is our show where our
friends do their stand up and we're
writing tags off to the side and then we
pitch them and tags
for all that stuff danielvankirk.com if
you want to find out where Dan's doing
yeah every other week Irene two and I
have a show at the cat's crawl it's
right where Melrose meets the 101. uh
every other Monday the scars did it back
on May 8th so you should come do it if
you haven't other than that you can
check me around town
um sets at The Comedy Store and I'm
gonna tell some days your podcast pen
pal says so check it out and also like
if you haven't checked out our patreon
right here for dumb people join our page
if you like the three of us hanging and
goofing you like this it's just more of
that [__] porn I got green leaves I'm
doing over there oh I love it only there
it's only five bucks a month Dan
undercooked tell me about the book and
was it somewhat born out of the podcast
or I know you love food stuff you're a
foodie it was born out of uh um all the
food stuff the podcast obviously you
guys were on you taught me about Imo's
Pizza
under the lock door during a hostage
crisis I have not tried it yet but I am
so fascinated by
yes what is it what is that cheese no
one knows it's a provolone no no it's
got some sort of a veil you know there's
a Vel there's no velvet very good steel
jizz as a binding agent I don't know
Imo's Pizza is just something you eat
while waiting for your tea wraps to cool
off thank you I need to try this goddamn
Pizza are they on gold belly yes are
they yes a what are you serious they
were I'm imaginable I get it and I would
and let me recommend I mean they can
send it to get a hamburger get hamburger
they also do a thing you know where they
have hamburger pizza emails will also
ship it to you directly
yeah yeah it's like comes flash frozen
and you gotta heat it up oh man get the
hamburger pizza okay that's the one okay
all right it doesn't really make a
difference I want to know what this is
and what are people getting because
people are going to buy this book so
okay it's a lot of Standalone essays
comedic essays about food sort of like
uh I'm being compared to uh David
Sedaris
of food you're like the Amy Sedaris of
David sedaris's I am the Amos Darius of
Davis Derek I'm the Dan yeah and just
like I'm the Dan to Danny yeah
um and uh yeah it's uh the people are
liking it best seller on Amazon yeah
it's uh if you like food if you like
comedy it's got heart it's got all those
wonderful things it's a labor of love
it's the worst thing I've ever had to do
it's hard it's very hard how long did it
take year year to write yeah so people I
mean we're I love food too I love going
whenever we go to into a town I'm always
like where should we be eating like talk
to the locals who know their no their
stuff yeah we were just in Austin Texas
for the moon tower Comedy Festival and
our buddy Matt Bearden who's a uh he
should be a James Beard award-winning
comic that's I'm going to call him a
James Beard award-winning comic because
he knows his food specifically in Austin
he gave us like three suggestions of
places all of them were great all of
them were so top shelf and I can't tell
you how happy it made me so I I feel
like there's a deep Fascination ours is
you know because we travel around and do
that but people are that passionate
about that yeah to then read a book
that's like funny and talking about
essays essays that are kind of about
food I love it Dan hold it up it is uh
yeah it's a it's it's fun we got blurbs
I got blurbs I love the yogurt I love it
I got blurbs from oh yeah
um
a lot of the comics are co-signing so
yeah I mean I love this artwork yeah the
artwork is very fun very cool I have I
did it myself beautiful did you no not
at all and but yeah the kids are liking
it it's always weird because you know we
do comedy we don't do book right that's
right we don't do bookity so okay it's
very strange because we're used to
getting instant feedback right away
imagine just writing a set for a year
never having practiced it and just
sending it out into the whole universe
how I let food become my life Navigator
and how maybe that's a dumb way to live
okay perfect for dumb people around
perfect for dumping amen first of all
those people who have seen you on
bajillion dollar properties it's one of
my favorite shows of all time if you
aren't a fan you will watch this show
and become a huge fan of yours and then
you'll want to get this book undercooked
available anywhere Amazon is probably
the place to get it right Amazon's the
easy place to get it I'm supposed to
tell you to go to go to your local
grocery store go do it but they're dicks
man I've been going to them to sign my
books they're never nice you go to
Barnes Noble nicest people wow really
because they're trying to stay afloat
because they're starting to understand
well it's also
all right here we go another story we're
gonna give dicks let's do it uh get the
book we'll remind you later thank you uh
sent in by Sean Anderson at Sean
s-h-a-w-n-e-70
Polk suspects call 9-1-1 to ask deputies
for help moving items from home they
were burglarizing officially I mean this
is when you call for backup that's top
tier down so these guys what kind of
drugs are you on I don't know Red Bull
but idiot yeah that's right so these
guys are the masters of admitting their
wrongdoing
and then trying to like once I admit it
we're all good right I'm fine I'm
telling you know that any just the idea
that even if it was your own stuff
you're like I'm gonna call the cops to
have them come help us move this couch
yeah exactly even that's stupid maybe
call a mover right you're supposed to
call a mover and say oh yeah my stuff
and the 911 is easier it's like you have
to look at it you guys move between the
window of 1am and 3 A.M and can you be
very quiet when you're doing it
Poinciana Florida
we've never done a story Point Sienna
two people in Poinciana were arrested
it's Royal Pon Sienna there's like a
tree a royal Ponce and it's beautiful
guys over here
he's he's the arborist that by the way a
show on CBS The Arbor remember the
mentalists yes that solves crimes using
his brain you mean like every other
investigator every detective on this
planet if he uses his brain
oh he's a mentalist he thinks about [__]
all right two people in Poinciana
Florida were arrested after one of them
made a 9-1-1 call to get help moving
their belongings from a home they were
burglarizing according to Sheriff's
right wildly dumb officials said no one
spoke on the other end of the Call Polk
County deputies the dispatcher I don't
know that's a very confusing this is bad
journalism no one spoke on which end of
them did they call and say we need help
burglarizing and the cops were like
because you have to assume the
dispatcher did their job nice guys what
are we doing here what do we say I don't
know just and find out where they
actually acquired to right now quiet or
do they call not say anything and the
9-1-1 operator was just guessing do you
guys need help what's going on over
there what's going on actually tell your
movies what are you moving stuff if I
can hear you you need our help hang up
are you burglar like it's like the
conversation with like Lassie yeah
you're burglarizing a house
there's kids who are sick all right just
hang up but it doesn't count look who's
at Steven Seagal
um I need help here we go officials said
no one's talking to another call Polk
County deputies responded to the house
at first thought no one was inside sure
they found an unlocked sliding glass
door in the back and entered yeah they
lock your sliding glass doors people
well these guys don't they then found a
male and female suspect identified they
wouldn't lock it it's not their house
right yeah well I don't care
um identified as we're not gonna I'll
tell you their ages at the end okay
Martin Gonzalez Garcia
mggy Ashley
it turned out deputies were searching
for Gonzalez Garcia okay
who is the new Rizzoli and Isle stop uh
after identifying him from a security
video as a burglary suspect at a Dollar
General store in Kissimmee okay they
said far they said he took several items
kissing me is it far from the kitchen
they must have fun novelty t-shirts yeah
she's kissing me
dude kissing me once kissing me twice
come on pretty baby kissing me deadly
what is This Kiss Me Deadly you remember
that song how was that no
who is it
leaderboard thank you
for The Runaways thank you Aaron thanks
for being there for me bud they said he
took several items earlier another day
right uh earlier in that day sorry how
many cases of Red Bull according to the
deputies the couples were staying in the
rest my reporter knew what they were
doing this reporter was all over that
has no idea couple said they were
staying in the residence because they
needed to find a place to stay for the
night so that's all not alive
that is a seven-year-old's excuse why
are you staying here because we need a
place
putting it together post Miranda Martin
stated on a recorded statement that he
did commit the burglary at the dollar
this guy doesn't live on anything I
committed the burglary at the Dollar
General store because he needed to get
items to sell to make money he's just
saying what he's doing I appreciate the
honesty what if I was just totally
honest yeah yeah
he's gonna get out of jail he's gonna
write a book and it's gonna be like a
self-help book called totally honest
yeah how honesty you know helped me get
in and out of crime and he's going to be
a bestseller it's going to become on
your podcast it's going to be called
meth cooked meth cooked Martin said he
knew what he did was wrong but he needed
the money that's right
I'm just being honest I'm stealing this
because I need the money I need the
money what he stated he knew that the
residence was not his and did not have
permission to be in it but he had to get
inside to get out of the cold that's
fair too I don't if you if your voice
doesn't make it right I don't understand
what you don't care about why I stole
okay get out of the cold I stole the
things because I need the money and I'm
in the house listen Gonzalez I'm gonna
teach you to be the best criminal ever
but here's the thing you got to be
honest just 100 honest all the way
through all the way all the way through
and be shocked that they don't know why
you're doing it I am surprised I should
pretend that I you no you be honest be
honest and then when they don't when
they're shocked that I'm being so honest
how do I handle it you double down
down on the honesty and you've been a
criminal coach for how long and you know
I went to University of Phoenix oh
online coaching criminals were you
criminal criminology major or criminal
coaching major
um I was a I was a CCM
coaching major you know and you minored
in what
um I minored in lying lying lying how do
I know if you're telling the truth right
there
studies but again it's how good he is
that's how good he is a side course all
right here we go
um the home is located this is it along
Cardinal Court deputies said they spoke
with the realtor agent who said he
didn't give the suspects permission to
be inside of course he didn't no and he
was his house they could have told you
that so this house is empty it's for
sale he didn't know either also is it
real realtor or realtor realtor realtor
okay realtor agent I just think you said
realtor I probably did okay um well
talking to deputies Roldan Ocasio told
him that she could jillion dollar
properties you don't mess with this he
knows what a realtor is told them that
she called 9-1-1 is it Skeletor or
Skeletor it's it's regional it depends
where you're from uh well talking to the
deputies Here We Go Again Roldan Ocasio
told them that she had called 9-1-1 this
is the scene from Goonies he's
essentially chunk right and then in the
second grade right yeah I'm starting to
like this kid I love this kid uh purpose
of having law enforcement help them move
their belongings from the house they
burglarize according to the agency we
just called the cops because we needed
help moving our belongings that we were
trying to steal like they're just laying
out everything they did wrong this guy's
really again because most people lie in
that instance
we're gonna go so straightforward and
pretend like why aren't you getting what
we're saying they also wanted to get a
ride to the airport so they can spend
the weekend in New York come on you made
that up yeah no that's true that's in
the article they also want to get a ride
to the airport so they can spend the
weekend in New York the reason why we
called you guys over here is to help us
move the stuff
so we can fly to New York why is that
such a bad thing can you can you guys
just do that wait but you said you
wanted to get into the house to get away
from the cold which we are for the night
and then tomorrow we're going to figure
out New York's cold in Florida this
store is not lining yeah go to the floor
they go to New York for the winner all
right deputies did help them with their
belongings and did give them a ride but
it wasn't to the airport it was to the
poke pokey
pokey and this person needs
the sheriff's office said in a Facebook
post you can yeah
yeah and they are welcome to stay there
all weekend long the poke pokey is much
better than New York anyway you guys
throwing Jabs in New York tired shots
fired up over there that's probably one
of the gold hey New York take this from
us yeah our jails are better than you
yeah the Santa's 2024. yeah yeah take
that Disney uh Gonzalez Garcia was
charged with burglary theft related to
the store also burglary of a resonance
Roldan okassi was charged with burglary
over residence they are also facing
charges of possession of cannabis at
this at this stage come on this is drug
paraphernalia deputies said neither have
medical marijuana cards what about like
calling 9-1-1 with a false we only don't
have medical marijuana cards because we
didn't get them because we don't have an
ailment that needs it man why is that
about it that's the reason we don't have
why is that wrong we're taking these
people's stuff because we need the money
somebody told these guys if you confess
too much they're gonna be like that's
right no anxiety whatsoever or back
again figure out how old they are let's
figure out how old they are oh they're
one year apart so let's guess the age in
between there is yeah no because because
then it's we'd know then you get it
right something and a half so let's
let's go around and guess the age of 33
and a half 33 and a half is in between
what's in between uh I'm gonna prices
write you and say 34 and a half 34.5
I'm gonna go
26 and a half all right get your answers
in shout out your ham radios okay
the age that is right in between these
two is 22 and a half oh Daniel they're
young wow tell the truth
be honest
ly like young enough to be like just
like there's like yeah they're police
you can't lie to them yeah exactly yeah
can't lie though because they're them
talking so much made me feel like they
were older but you guys had that pinned
down all right I've got my third story
yeah about a man who did a a very long
play uh practical joke and then like
that then he had to stop doing it like
that run-on sentence all of that uh
Diana dude is our guest he's got a new
book called undercooked go get it in
Amazon or at a small bookstore if you
like dealing with the attitude and then
we'll be right back back with more dumb
people time right after this
[Music]
I want to learn Italian what's what's
amazing is I went to Italy last year and
I while I was there I thought man I wish
I knew this better I know Spanish and a
little bit of French but like I said I
want to learn Italian because I know I'm
going to be back in Italy I just had
such a wonderful time so I started with
the Babel program
and I was like trying to it's amazing on
my phone and I was just walking up to my
friend Peter's house who's in my
neighborhood and I said I wonder if I
can do a lesson while I'm walking sure
and I'm walking through my neighborhood
and the lessons are so easy they're like
little games and multiple choice
questions and then they do a good job of
reviewing it too that's right and they
hear you know it makes me mad when I get
too wrong
wait I got two wrong on one so then I
went back and they let you redo them
again to get that perfect
I'm a very complete yeah you want to get
the Perfect Score but what I was saying
is it just was I felt so it was so fun
to just be walking my neighborhood and
like hearing the Italian and like I
would speak it at the top of my lungs it
was so bad that's awesome
yeah I do feel it's coming along I
definitely feel like I'm more
comfortable yeah and it's a very easy
way to learn a language I love how they
lay it out yeah I love that Babel is
real language learning for real
conversations that's one of their one of
their points that I love about them
studies from Yale uh the best university
in Michigan Michigan State University
and others continue to prove Babel is
better for instance one study found that
using Babel for 15 hours is equivalent
to a full semester at College it's
unbelievable so guys we have a special
limited time deal for our listeners you
can get started right now get 55 off
your Babel script subscription that's 55
but only for our listeners go to
babel.com
DPT get 55 off babel.com TBT spelled
b-a-b-b-e-l.com slash TPT rules and
restrictions
hey guys welcome back to the show I'm
gonna take us home Dana dude again one
more time undercooked undercook this
thing I'm gonna undercook another time
also you know in uh was it you got mail
where Meg Ryan runs a little bookstore
yeah um was that you got mail was it I
don't know which one is the one word she
breaks up in Seattle because he has like
sleep apnea
probably Sleepless in Seattle yeah I
hate that one but she was she she was
like snotty and mean and uh you got mail
wasn't she she's naughty and mean yeah
she was she on that bookstore she was
mean to Tom Hanks all I wanted to do was
bring more capitalism
about how much mail could she have you
guys ready it's so much mail who's ready
for a final story sent in by our good
friend Carlene McDermott at chibi
Carlene we love her you ready for this
here is and I had to adjust this Dan's
teaching me well why so Daniel's Daniel
teaching me well so Dan and dude we used
to do it where Dan did all Daniel did
all three stories now each of us do a
story so we're learning the tricks of
the trade how to hold back information
you let people guess it's a master he's
a Jedi yes students are becoming here we
go here is the headline that I had to
alter man ends several years-long
langdiggly airport sign joke that cost a
lot of money okay and so he's in on this
gag for years and years and years for a
long time a billboard for Lang diggly
International has been a landmark near
near Poe's Village this is in England it
looks like an ordinary road sign but
actually signpost to an airport that
only exists in people's imagination
right so there's a sign for an airport
airport this way but is it an airport no
it's only an airport of the Mind did you
know they do this at the Austin Airport
what there's that weird gate that says
like you can time travel oh it has all
these fake playing like all these fake
oh that's uh departures for things that
aren't real that's going off to the
something system and the Dagobah system
that would work anyway uh which I think
is a little right it goes after Italians
right no stop anyway
it looks like an ordinary road sign
only exists in people's imagination
after spending many many pounds to erect
and maintain the sign the owner decided
it's time to take it down Okay so this
guy some a very long time ago based on
our the vague headline you created
Spence
over a year well maybe years could be
days I assume years that's just I said
years long in the title oh you did okay
so to upkeep a sign to a fake airport
rep and now he's now decided I need time
for me to move on I can't carry this is
a joke that no one laughed at and he
laughed loudly to cover the fact that
when he would tell people he's doing
this no one's laughing gotcha so since
and I'm not going to say the year if you
travel eastwards toward the a44 between
raihedar and Kingpin you will see a sign
directing drivers to terminals one and
three of Lang diddly in uh playing
deadly international airport but drive
the two and a half miles as instructed
and you will end up not an airport not
even in an Airfield but just a field on
the outskirts of the village of landedly
powers got him this got him got him
here's the link and you don't even
you're not even there when they get
pranked that's it
it looks like a real sign very much
actually the specificity of of the
signage one and three okay terminals one
and three yeah of course this isn't
illegal in all these years I haven't had
not that I think it should be enforced
in all these years I haven't had a
single complaint said Nicholas Whitehead
yeah you know why because no one wants
to go to the airport yeah so no one
cares about it also in all these years
you haven't had a complaint because
people have Google Maps yeah and it
shows them that there's no such place as
the airport nor would they be going to
that and there's probably no airport
near it so I kind of love this guy
listens The Man Behind a Nicholas
Whitehead is a journalist who used to
edit the Radner edition of the Brecken
and Radner Express and once wrote with
Monty Python's Terry Jones oh wow he
said quote it started off as a wild
conversation with friends one evening
and landigly we thought of renting a
sign for something that wasn't really
there possibly a project that didn't
exist and we settled on the airport it
started off as a bit of a joke then we
realized it was actually possible it was
made by rexim signs rexham we know them
welcome to wrexham given the okay one
thing led to another and there it is Mr
Whitehead added as a journalist whatever
you do someone somewhere is going to get
upset about it so this guy's like I
don't want to hear it even if I did
nothing they'd be mad at me it's also
perfect for dump people because in dumb
people time there would be signs for an
airport that does not exist however this
particular joke has seemingly been
popular among the locals interests like
former farmer Neil Richard said the
fictitious former farmer former farmer
but he's a farmer former Neil Richard
says the fictitious airport draws
tourists to the area in all the years I
haven't had a single complaint about
laying to Glee internationally said
loads of people love it some people
might not get it but as far as I know
nobody's upset or angry about it there's
no nothing to get that's a first two of
the planes from 911 started there
originated that's yeah that's true it
has cost that's about how much in pounds
per year to maintain this bill what do
you got to do wipe it down many pounds
that's what we know you got to have that
I don't know I don't know why they cost
pounds what do you think it's true what
is the mayor I think you have to rent
the billboard space Oh
that could be then I'll go 100 pounds a
year 100 pounds a year what are you 50
what do you think
I'm gonna say a thousand pounds okay get
your answers in town is because
1500 pounds wow for this joke this dumb
joke I mean like that's so British to
like dig your heels in and be like I'm
gonna keep doing this joke right here Mr
White we don't even know how many years
he's been doing it hey it's time to call
it a day right so we're gonna figure out
how much money has gone into this thing
I think the airport is established now
and I think the establishment should
take it on it's not enough it's not the
joke might be it's not exactly a
National Monument but it's a national
treasure you don't get to say that yeah
right other people get to say that
uh he hopes that Welsh governments
Heritage body if it were a National
Treasure they wouldn't let him just stop
that's right they'd say we're keeping it
c-a-d-w may be interesting to make a
movie about it it became an item of
Welsh Heritage it wouldn't cost them
anything like as much as it cost me in
terms of value of money it's um he's
basically run out of money to pay for it
tell everybody you have an extra 15. hey
well I got news to you Holly Richards
who lives in Langley said this signs
part of our community
literally speaking yes at a nearby
service station she fell face down in
front of a pub a nearby service station
in Crossgates a cafe popular with bikers
locals said they were sad to see
Landmark oh Holly Richards then added I
lived in Langley all my life the science
part of our community it's a bit of a
running gag people joke like they've
just flown into Langley and they're
flying back out tomorrow it's a
wonderful feature why can't you just say
that anyway if the sign goes down you
can't also if the whole town likes it
get together George Bailey and get
together like 1500 every time we see it
me and my mates have a giggle I asked my
mom all about it when I was young and
I'd be uh and I'd like to be able to
tell my own kids about that you can't
tell your kids about it
wait when I was young that means this
thing is probably oh she said I've been
here all right so here's my thing farmer
or on your lawn former forearm farmer
former farmer forearm Neil Richards that
he helped Foreman it helped put the
village on the map there's no end of
people who've seen it it was already on
the map who's who stopped it no it isn't
on the map stopped at our farm at the
edge of the Radner Forest asking how to
find the airport he said apparently two
American Air Force planes landed nearby
as part of a military mission in World
War II the airport has also taken off
big way on social media thousands of
followers across across Facebook and
Twitter enjoy updates about landed Lee's
impressible so that's the environment in
750. and engage in Flight some fancy top
secret terminal 2.
so factor that in when you talk about a
how long it's been out let's figure out
what the average price would be once we
know the years so how long has it been
up
I'm gonna go long okay what do you think
he's been maintaining this right now
Walter Payton I'm gonna go 34 years what
do you think 41 years what do you think
20 years one of you
is exactly right no [__] now do you want
to stay at 35 I'm the only one with a
weird number what do you think mine do
you think I'm ever gonna knock you think
I'm not gonna stick with Walter you like
to stick with 41 I'm sticking with 40
Sigma 34. I'm sorry I thought you did 40
41. you I'll go 34 I'm staying with it
you can stay I'm sticking with 20. based
on what the font of the sign was no
looks like a youngest oh a newish fun
all right get your answers in town
because that sign has been up remember
that woman said I've been her I've been
telling my whole life so does she mean
I've always been here and I love that or
it's been here for as long as she moved
there you don't know yeah okay so it's
been in town and it's been up for 20
years
dude I'm talking about author Dana dude
of the book undercooked so let's figure
out this thing really quickly 1500 it's
not always been that 20 years I bet 900
bucks if you average it out over 20
years because it probably was way under
so so you're saying somewhere around a
thousand no you're saying nineteen
thousand pounds yeah right I'm saying
eighteen thousand I thought almost a
thousand a year yeah right so you say
eighteen thousand twenty eighteen
thousand pounds when we say twenty five
thousand twenty five thousand what do
you say uh nineteen thousand what do you
think what's the conversion on that one
of you is exactly right shut up okay
wait you said what I didn't know we were
guessing eighteen eighteen nine nineteen
twenty five because you said 900 is
about the average and so I'm sticking
with 18. I'm sticking with 19. I'm
getting my calculator out and I'm
staying because of the font of the song
he was right before all right you ready
you ready yeah come on get your answers
in town he's shot him at your ham radios
because this sign as a joke Nicholas
Whitehead for 20 years 25
000.
what's up all right the book is called
undercooked pick it up wherever you pick
up books go see us live go see Dan show
with Irene too at the cat's crawl uh go
see our Target show at The Comedy Store
superscars.com is the what it is and uh
come see us live we're in a town near
you we'll let you know about other stuff
that's going on can I plug some extra go
for it yeah please follow me on the
socials at stand up Dan and uh listen to
my podcast Green Eggs and Dan which we
were on which we loved which we loved it
very fun and uh yeah undercooked baby I
love it there you go boom boom Dana dude
you're wonderful I love that you were
here with us and oh [__] recovery we
gotta get back to work guys
town
[Music]